EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
GUN CONTROL SAVES LIVES.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TELLING ME
DAY AND NIGHT ON CNN.
IN FACT, THEY ARE HAVING A
TOWN HALL MEETING TOMORROW NIGHT
TO TELL YOU SOME MORE ANYONE WHO
OPPOSES GUN CONTROL WILL TELL
YOU BY IMPLICATION OF NOT
DIRECTLY THAT IT'S A BAD PERSON.
A CHALICE, CRUEL, PROBABLY
VIOLENT PERSON BE IT SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
OTHERS.
WHILE, LAST NIGHT A BRUISE GOES
PROGRESSIVE ACTIVATES TOOK THAT
VERY MESSAGE TO SENATOR MAJORITY
LEADERS MITCH McCONNELL'S
HOME.
HERE'S WHAT THEY SAID.
>> WE ARE AT MITCH McCONNELL'S
HOUSE.
HE'S ABOUT TO GET SOME REST?
NOT IF IT KILLS THE CHILDREN YOU
ARE KIDNAPPING.
NOT IF FAMILIES ARE GETTING
MURDERED CAN'T GET ANY REST.
HE'S IN THAT, NURSING HIS LITTLE
BROKEN ARM.
HE SHOULD HAVE BROKEN HIS
WRINKLED NECK.
IT MURDER TURTLE!
MURDER TURTLE!
STABBED HIM IN THE HEART!
>> Tucker: STABBED HIM IN THE
HEART.
BREAK HIS NECK.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE TO
MITCH McCONNELL BID THEY ARE
TOTALLY OPPOSED TO VIOLENCE AND
THAT'S WHY WHAT THEY WANT TO
KILL MITCH McCONNELL.
IF YOU ARE CONFUSED, YOU HAVEN'T
BEEN PAYING MUCH ATTENTION
LATELY.
ALMOST EVERYTHING THE LEFT SAYS
THESE DAYS IS PROJECTION.
IN ALMOST EVERY SINGLE CASE,
THEY ACCUSE YOU OF EXACTLY WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
AND THIS WEEK WAS NO DIFFERENT.
IN THE WAKE OF TWO HORRIFYING
MASS SHOOTINGS, THEY'VE BEEN
TELLING US THE PRESIDENT IS A
HATER.
HE IS USING RACE TO DIVIDE US,
THEY SCREAM!
IT'S WRONG!
WHILE, THEY ARE RIGHT ABOUT THE
SECOND PACK.
IT'S ACTUALLY WRONG.
BUT USING RACE TO DIVIDE US,
THAT'S OF COURTS IN AND OF THE
LEFT.
BUT ON MY POLITICS THE PROCESS
OF DIVIDING PEOPLE ON THE BASIS
OF IMMUTABLE CHARACTERISTICS.
FACTORS THAT CAN CONTROL.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS AT THIS
POINT.
IT'S AN IDENTITY POLITICS PARTY.
THEY PROMISED SOME AMERICANS
REPARATIONS, THEY DENOUNCE
OTHERS FOR THEIR SKIN COLOR.
THEY CALL IT PRIVILEGE.
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY, THEY WILL
TELL YOU, IS FUNDAMENTALLY
RACIST AND THEREFORE EVIL.
>> THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON
WHITE SUPREMACY AND EVERY SINGLE
INSTITUTION AND STRUCTURE THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR COUNTRY STILL
REFLECTS THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY
AND SEGREGATION AND JIM CROW AND
ITS OPPRESSION.
EVEN IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> YOU CAN'T DO BLIND TO THE
IMPACT OF GENERATIONS OF RACISM
AND WHITE SUPREMACY THAT WERE
WRITTEN INTO OUR LAWS OVER
CENTURIES.
>> Tucker: SO THEY ARE
BUFFOONS.
YES THEY ARE.
THEY ARE DOWN.
OF COURSE.
DO THEY HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THEY
ARE REALLY SAYING?
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MAKE THE
CUMULATIVE EFFECT ANY LESS
SINISTER OR DAMAGING.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING, WHAT USE
ON THOSE TAPES THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING EVERY DAY, IT'S A
SYSTEMATIC EFFORT BY THE LEFT TO
UNDERMINE THE
HOLD THIS COUNTRY TOGETHER.
CHIEF AMONG THOSE INSTITUTIONS
IN THIS AND ALL SOCIETIES
THROUGHOUT TIME IS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OVER THE PAST 25 YEARS, THAT'S
BEEN A SUCCESS STORY.
AMERICA'S COPS HAVE RADICALLY
REDUCED CRIME ACROSS THIS
NATION.
THEY BROUGHT OUR CITIES BACK TO
LIFE.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT, YOU ARE
OBVIOUSLY UNDER 40.
ASK ANYBODY WHO LIVED IN
NEW YORK CITY IN 1991 WHAT IT
WAS LIKE.
THAT PERSON'S HONEST.
YOU WILL BE GRATEFUL FOR WHAT
THE COPS DID.
BUT NOW, ON THE BASIS OF NO
EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER, THE LEFT IS
TELLING US POLICE ARE RACIST
MONSTERS.
>> I HAVE CHALLENGED OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF
THE WAYS IN WHICH THE UNIFORM
THAT HAS BEEN BURDENED BY
RACISM.
WE ARE GOING TO CRACK DOWN ON
POLICE BRUTALITY AND PRIMARILY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> TRAINING FOR POLICE OFFICERS
ON IMPLICIT RACES WHY BIAS IS
DENYING TO IT EXISTS IS DENYING
LIBERTY AND MEANT CASES COME
ALIVE.
>> HOW CAN WE CONTINUE TO LOSE
THE LIVES OF UNARMED BLACK MEN
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AT THE HANDS OF WHITE POLICE
OFFICERS QUESTION MIKE THAT IS
NOT JUSTICE.
>> IF YOU ARE YOUNG AND BLACK,
YOU ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF YOUR
SKIN.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT'S JUST
THE CASE OF A FEW BAD APPLES.
I BELIEVE THAT THE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE IF YOU WERE
A COP OR YOUR DAD WAS A COP OR
YOUR SON WAS A CALL.
HAVING TO SIT AND WATCH THAT
SLANDER DAY AFTER DAY.
AGAIN COME ON THE BASIS OF NO
EVIDENCE THEY ARE SAYING THAT.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
DIVIDING IS QUESTION MIKE OH,
YES, THEY ARE DIVIDING US.
OR HOW ABOUT OUR THOUSANDS OF
I.C.E. AGENTS WORKING TO ENFORCE
LAW THAT THE CONGRESS PASSED.
CONGRESS PASSES THE LAWS AND
THEN HIRES PEOPLE.
IT DOESN'T PAY THEM ALL THAT
MUCH.
TO ENFORCE THEIR LAWS.
THAT OUT NOW DEMOCRATS ARE
CALLING THOSE PEOPLE.
GOOD PEOPLE DOING A THANKLESS
JOB THAT WE NEED TO HAVE DONE.
ONLY TO HAVE SOME PAMPERED LIKE
A CAUSEY OF CORTEZ SAVAGE THEM
FOR CLINICAL REASONS.
NONE OF THIS IS NEW BY THE WAY
PURE TWO YEARS AGO THE CLINTON
RAN AN ENTIRE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN ON THIS PREMISE.
ATTACKING THE COUNTRY ITSELF AND
ITS PEOPLE AS IMMORAL BIGOTS.
>> YOU COULD PUT HALF OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S INTO WHAT I CALL THE
BASKET OF DEPLORABLES.
IT RACIST, HOMOPHOBIC,
XENOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC, YOU
NAME IT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE MESSAGE
OF UNITY?
NO.
IT'S THE MESSAGE OF DISUNITY.
IT'S THE MESSAGE OF HATE.
THINK THROUGH THE APPLICATIONS
OF IT.
IF RACIST, SEXIST, XENOPHOBIC,
WHAT YOU DO TO PEOPLE LIKE THAT?
DO YOU TRY TO HELP THEM?
TO FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
COUNTRYMEN, YOUR BROTHER'S?
NO.
THEY ARE HORRIBLE.
YOU TRY TO DESTROY THEM AND THEY
ARE TRYING TO DESTROY THEM.
YESTERDAY, TEXAS DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN WALKING CASTRO'S, WE
ARE NOT MAKING THIS OUT, BY THE
WAY, TWEETED OUT THE NAMES OF 44
RESIDENTS OF SAN ANTONIO WHO
DONATED TO THE DONALD TRUMP'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
BUT THEN HE TWEETED OUT THE
NAMES OF THEIR EMPLOYERS, TOO.
WHY DO YOU THINK HE DID THAT
QUESTION MIKE HEAT YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL TONIGHT IF
YOU WERE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE?
WOULD YOU FEEL SICK QUESTION
MIKE 21.
THAT'S FINE WITH CONGRESSMAN
CASTRO THOUGH.
HIS POINT IS REALLY CLEAR.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHY HE DID
THAT.
IF SOMEONE GETS HURT, THAT'S ON
HIS PROBLEM.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THIS IS GOING.
IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT
"THE BOSTON GLOBE" RAN AN OP-ED
SUGGESTING THAT RESTAURANT
WORKERS POISONED THE FOOD OF
TRUMP SUPPORTER'S AND OF COURSE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN CALLING ON
PEOPLE TO HARASS AND SCREAM AT
PEOPLE TIED TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FOR YEARS.
GO TO THE HILT TODAY!
GET UP AND FREE?
GOAT GO UP IN THE FACE OF
CONGRESSPEOPLE.
YOU GET OUT AND YOU'LL GET WHAT
YOU WANT.
YOU TELL THEM WILL COME!
>> Tucker: SO YES, THESE
PEOPLE ARE BUFFOONS.
AND IT'S OUR FAULT, SOMETIMES,
IF WE ARE BEING HONEST,
INCLUDING THE SHOW, FOR
HIGHLIGHTING WHAT BUFFOONS THEY
ARE.
BECAUSE BY DOING THAT, WE
UNDERPLAY HOW DANGEROUS THEIR
RHETORIC IS.
OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM ONLY WORKS
WHEN CITIZENS ARE FREE TO
DISAGREE.
FOR YOU TO SAY THAT THEIR
NEIGHBORS RUN SEPARATE PAGES BUT
WE WILL FIRST UPROOT PEOPLE.
AND NOT BE AFRAID TO SAY THAT.
BUT THE LEFT IS MAKING US AFRAID
TO SAY THAT.
THE LEFT DEMANDS TOTAL
CONFORMITY.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN DIVERSITY.
THEY WILL USE CENSORSHIP AND
THREATS TO KEY PEOPLE IN LINE
AND IN THE SHORT-TERM, THEY MAY
WORK.
THEY ARE HOPING IT WORKS UNTIL